[Music]
on this friday night an unexpected delay
in canada's vaccine rollout
why doses of the pfizer biontec vaccine
are about to be slashed in half
this kind of issue is out of our hands
as bleak projections are made
about the second wave and fear's
increase a more contagious
variant could spread like wildfire more
people are going to become infected with
it
plus saskatchewan's rising cases and
rising anger
over rule breakers go work in the care
home for a couple days and see how you
feel
and turning their backs on trump it was
a tough thing to abandon
the republicans who have had enough our
mike armstrong
is in trump country
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us i
really wish i had some good news to
start off the newscast tonight
but i'm sorry there just isn't any we're
still in the throes of the pandemic of
course and now
even the glimmer of hope of vaccines is
a bit dimmer
the federal government has announced
shipments of the pfizer biontech vaccine
will be reduced by
50 percent over the next four weeks it's
one of the two vaccines
being given to canadians right now the
problem is a shortage of vaccine being
produced at pfizer's manufacturing
facility in belgium where canada
gets its doses pfizer the government
says is pausing some production lines
there so it can
expand long-term manufacturing capacity
the biggest impact on canada will be
january 25th
its hope shipments will then be back on
track
by the end of february this
does not impact our goal to have enough
vaccines available by september
for every canadian who wants one it does
mean vaccine rollout already slow will
get
even slower in the weeks ahead at the
same time new projections are out today
that paint a grim picture of the
trajectory of this second wave in canada
at current infection rates we're likely
to see an increase of more than two
hundred thousand new cases of covid19
over the next
nine days and roughly two thousand more
canadians could die
that would push the death toll to twenty
thousand in canada
the global death toll hit another
milestone today surpassing
two million on top of all this new
faster spreading variants are now being
detected
in multiple countries including in
canada it's not believed they lead to
more severe
illness but they are much more
contagious and case counts could
skyrocket in ways the health system
is simply not prepared for mike gerlay
has our top story
tonight two weeks into the new year a
dire warning from canada's top doctor
follow public health protocols or even
darker days are ahead
because in so many areas of the country
the virus is spreading in the community
the moment that you lift some of those
or increase contacts basically for
individuals
it's expected that the virus will surge
the latest projections show a surge to
10 000 cases a day
even if we maintain the status quo an
increase in community contacts
could see the case load rise above 30
thousand per day
the only avenue to a decrease is if
canadians heed the warnings
i know this isn't how you wanted to
start the new year
it probably feels like at deja vu all
over again from 2020
this won't last forever but for now we
have to buckle down
looking at the numbers the growth of the
second wave is showing no signs of
slowing down with an average of 7 900
new cases per day
which is four times as many as the peak
in the first wave
and the number of canadians dying from
covet 19 continues to rise as well it's
expected to soon surpass the peak from
the spring
when healthcare professionals were still
trying to understand the virus
and that's troubling for doctors who
worry they'll soon have to make
impossible choices
about who they try to save the health
care system underwrites so much more
the economy businesses jobs etc so we
really have not
got a true sense of the chaos that would
result if we allow that to happen
prime minister justin trudeau says he's
considering new restrictions including
potentially banning flights from some
countries
but he says it's up to the provinces to
create covet protocols that work for
them
and he implores canadians to follow them
microlight global news toronto something
is going
on in windsor ontario it has the fastest
growing number of new cases of covid19
in the province
it is right across from the united
states border today
the american centers for disease control
warned a much more contagious
variant of covid19 the one first
identified in the uk
is projected to become the dominant
source of infection in the u.s by march
the head of the windsor hospital fears
that fast spreading variant
is in his city too eric sorenson reports
it's an unnerving distinction windsor
essex has surpassed every region in
ontario for new covet 19
cases per capita the spread has
increased so quickly
that windsor regional hospital was
forced to send some patients
outside the region and has a temporary
morgue
in a trailer the hospital's chief of
staff thinks this could be the result of
the so-called uk variant
the efficient spread the wide range of
patients that are being
being infected with it and the pattern
that was very similar to what was
occurring
in the uk that triggered us to think
that this is a possibility that the uk
variant or some other mutation is
present in our community
windsor is a region on the front lines
health officials say many people were
mobile
over christmas and every day thousands
cross from the united states into
windsor
truckers with necessary food and goods
for the country
and health care workers from windsor who
work in detroit ontario's count of new
covet cases
shows windsor essex has spiked to 323
per 100
000 population per week the six regions
with the highest numbers
are the three in the highest population
area in and around toronto
plus windsor lambton and niagara which
all have
border crossings to the u.s that's
always in our concern
that any of these cases are we
bringing it back to windsor because of
the difference
in the prevalence of covet in
u.s the united states is a firestorm of
covet 19
and the growing worry is the new faster
spreading variant
the u.s center for disease control says
the new variant has the potential to
increase
the u.s pandemic trajectory and become
the dominant source of infection by
march
the fact that it's it spreads more
efficiently just by
simple math means more people are going
to become infected with it the more
people that are infected the more people
that are going to be hospitalized
and unfortunately the more people that
will then die public health ontario is
currently testing virus samples from
different parts of the province
windsor health officials expect to learn
next week if their samples turn up with
the new variant
that could explain the recent surge in
cases and suggest where it's coming from
eric sorensen global news toronto
these more contagious variants can only
be confirmed through genomic sequencing
which is
more complex than a simple covid test
right now the true scope of their spread
in canada
is not certain the uk variant was first
detected in canada last month in ontario
and since then
at least 23 cases have been found across
the country the bulk of them in ontario
two cases of a variant first detected in
south africa have been found
in bc and alberta saskatchewan's top
doctor is
threatening to bring down a hammer of
new health restrictions next week
the province continues to have the
highest rate of active cases per capita
in canada saskatchewan is averaging 313
new cases a day over the last week
there are fears that number could climb
to more than 1600
cases a day by the end of this month
ryan kessler reports on the additional
pressure this will have on the
province's health care system
this is my mom's sort of surviving
covert
when brian albert looks at pictures of
his mother he sees
resilience 98 year old marie albert
overcame the virus a feat they can only
celebrate from afar
i can't hold my mom's hand i can't
hug her she looks at me and she you know
gives me a virtual hug
marie lives in a regina care home where
at least 41 people have died from covet
19.
her son is done with people defying
public health orders
they're idiots they don't get it this is
not about one person this is a
this is a world thing you know it's not
even saskatchewan
saskatchewan has the highest active case
rate in canada with numbers increasing
fastest in saskatoon
the north and far north saskatchewan's
health authority has stated the system
is at its most fragile point in the
pandemic
one epidemiologist says it's time for
tougher measures
we need to declare that we will keep a
lockdown and
stricter restrictions in place until we
see
our numbers going down dr nazeem
muhajreen wants in-person dining halted
and banquet halls and gyms closed he
also says students may need to return to
online learning
the province's chief medical health
officer did not offer specifics
but warned of further restrictions if
case counts don't drop
we'll be lucky to maintain the status
quo it's not trending down and i think
that's something we really need to think
about
as of thursday saskatchewan's icu
capacity was at 95 percent
the biggest challenge is staffing the
saskatchewan union of nurses says
the province needs to consider scaling
back health services
now we have a vaccination program that
we need to get up and running
and we also have people's everyday
regular illnesses that must be dealt
with in a timely fashion
it's a big burden for saskatchewan's
front-line workers
and with case counts rising there is no
relief in sight
ryan kessler global news saskatoon
canadians have been told for months to
avoid non-essential travel but apart
from the atlantic bubble there's been no
restriction on travel between
provinces bc's premier says he is now
seeking legal advice to determine
whether an inter-provincial travel
ban is possible and constitutional put
this either to rest
so that british columbians understand
that we cannot do that
and we're not going to do that or there
is a way to do it and we're going to
work with other provinces to achieve it
prime minister justin trudeau has some
harsh words for the black quebecois
leader eve francois blanchette
blanchett in a statement in french said
questions
arise about canada's new transport
minister omar al-gabra
because of his former role as head of
the canadian arab federation
that kind of political
pandering to the worst elements into
fears and anxieties
has no place in canada and all of us
need to stand up
strongly to push back against that
anywhere it happens in this country the
block quebecois claims blanchette was
simply raising questions
about the minister's past people in
newfoundland and labrador are going to
the polls on february
13th premier andrew furies leads a
minority government and says with covet
19 numbers so low there the best and
safest time to vote
is now three other provinces have had a
general election
mind you with numbers far greater than
we have it'll be different
there's no question about it but we can
do it safely
and the democratic process will continue
just as normal life has continued in the
face of this pandemic
now to washington d.c prosecutors have
formally walked back their assertion
made in court filings
that the alleged capitol riders intended
to capture and assassinate elected
officials when they stormed the capitol
building
the acting attorney general in
washington d.c says there's no evidence
at this time
of catch and kill teams the washington
post reports the violent mob did come
perilously close to finding
vice president mike pence that day today
the area around the u.s capitol is
already under intense security five days
before president-elect joe biden is
inaugurated
jackson proskow reports
they call this the green zone an
unprecedented security perimeter ringing
the u.s
capitol the white house and most of
downtown washington
spectators are simply not welcome not at
a time like this
there's a great deal of very concerning
chatter
and it's what you don't know that we are
preparing for
ominous new details suggest the storming
of the capitol came perilously close to
a massacre
police officers described coming under
violent assault by the mob
guys were like grabbing gear off my vest
i remember guys chanting like killing
with his own gun
there's a probe into whether some
members of congress provided assistance
to the rioters
if they aided and abetted the crime
there may have to be actions taken
beyond the congress
and in terms of prosecution those same
lawmakers now say they fear further
violence
some are even purchasing body armor it's
sad that we have to get to that point
but you know our expectation is that
someone may try to kill us
the fbi warns the threat of domestic
terror attacks will not end with the
inauguration
and could come to the doorstep of cities
across the u.s
there's so much concern about security
in the coming days that a planned dress
rehearsal for the inauguration here on
the steps of the capitol for sunday
had to be called off at the same time
there's no no talk of closing
bridges into washington d.c from
neighboring virginia
and vehicles driving in and around the
city may even be subject to random
search in the days ahead donna
jackson president trump has five days
left usually the new president drives to
the inauguration with the outgoing
president
what do we know about trump's plans no
surprise
here he wants nothing to do with the
inauguration of his successor joe biden
in fact he's planning to fly to florida
first thing in the morning on the 20th
on inauguration day
he won't be anywhere near this he won't
have anything to do with the swearing-in
of biden
that's in stark contrast to vice
president mike pence who has indicated
he may well attend the ceremony and who
today phoned his successor
kamala harris to congratulate her on her
victory
okay jackson proskow in washington
thanks global news will have live
coverage of the inauguration from
washington d.c on wednesday morning at
11
eastern 8 pacific a strong earthquake
strikes
indonesia coming up the search for
survivors trapped in the wreckage
as the death toll climbs
a 6.2 magnitude earthquake hit indonesia
overnight a search is underway and at
least 42 people are known to have died
i just wanted to rescue teams are doing
all they can to reach the survivors the
quake toppled homes and businesses and
triggered landslides
thousands of people have been forced to
leave their homes
a political shock wave rocked the
netherlands today the entire dutch
government resigned after a scathing
report revealed
tax authorities unfairly targeted
thousands of poor families accusing them
of fraudulently claiming child benefits
prime minister mark root said political
responsibility for the scandal lay with
his cabinet which he said had decided
collectively it had no option but to
resign
the center-right party will continue to
run the netherlands in a caretaker
capacity and
oversee the kovid 19 vaccine rollout
until
an election in march ahead
office space in a pandemic can
businesses afford keeping them if
nobody's in them
the pandemic is having impacts in all
kinds of places a new real estate report
shows one in 10
offices across the country is vacant an
indication of how many people are
working from home
robin gill looks at what that means for
business owners leasing rows
of empty offices phoebe young doesn't
want to give up this view but she's the
only one at her company's vancouver
headquarters
normally 12 employees would fill up the
space but no one's coming in
we're looking at the the pure bottom
line right now
and you know over the last year we've
tried to keep our
ship afloat and thankfully we have and
we're doing well
but at the same time i think we have to
make some good business decisions right
now
80 percent of the time has been empty
so you do the math she's giving up the
lease like so many other businesses
leaving offices dark in major canadian
centers
downtown toronto for instance downtown
vancouver you're seeing
10 maybe 15 percent of the people who
used to come into the office are still
coming into the office
whereas when you start looking into the
suburban areas or more
car centric markets you're looking at
somewhere between 30 and 50 percent
attendance levels if companies aren't
using it they're losing it
boosting vacancy rates in vancouver it's
4.9 percent
up from 2.9 the year before in toronto
the rate is 6.2 percent compared to 5
in 2019 calgary has seen it the worst
a 25.7 percent vacancy rate
a double whammy of covert 19 and
alberta's economic downturn
where we've seen the biggest surge in
the vacancy has been in the sublease
market
and with tenants looking to sublease out
their space uh to
to another to another tenant and in that
market i think you're going to see
tenants begin who really want a
subleaser space begin to discount
that space when it is business as usual
there are predictions the office space
won't be the same and companies will
have to allow flexibility for working
from home you're not going to get them
back until they feel safe
it's more about the comfort levels it's
more about
how companies are going to allow people
to come back in the office
but still remain a little more spaced
out because they are cognizant of the
fact
that you know we have been very dense in
these office spaces over the last few
years
when phoebe young does get back into the
office it won't be full time
for myself is that i save like about an
hour of commute time
there and back and that's a lot of time
you can spend at your desk
as the boss she has a whole new view of
the hybrid situation
that has been presented to her and her
staff
robin gill global news vancouver
up next our mike armstrong crosses the
border and finds out why some
republicans
are abandoning trump
over the four years president trump has
been in the white house his support
among republicans has been nearly rock
solid
now cracks appeared to be developing
some longtime republicans have had
enough
mike armstrong is on the road in
pennsylvania and he's been talking
to some of them it was scary melissa dye
was working from home during the riot at
the capitol glued to her tv
what she watched she blames on donald
trump and the republican party
her party dye was a republican committee
member in lancaster county pennsylvania
but drew up a resignation letter that
same night
it was tough i've dedicated
10 plus years of my life to doing this
and to the party
and yeah it was a tough thing to abandon
this is the office in cumberland county
where people register their party
affiliation
they've been busy in the five days after
the ride in dc
190 republicans called to change their
party
statewide it was more than four thousand
there's a significant
division within the party that we're
going to have to face one way or another
gary eichelberger is a commissioner in
cumberland county and a republican
nervous about what he's seeing i easily
win eichelberger says republican
politicians questioning the integrity of
the election
led to poll workers being abused before
during
and after voting day
[Applause]
and then came the riot in d.c conspiracy
theories about voting machines or dead
voters have pushed
some in the party he says to reject
reality
you can't ignore those theories because
they've they've taken root
uh among a certain population that is uh
pretty sizable now
eichelberger fears the rejectionists in
his party may
push out the realists there's no exodus
at this point but he says if the
bleeding
doesn't stop it could hurt republican
strongholds he's feeling that
it could also hurt the country when our
very foundation of our representative
system
and our public institutions come into
doubt
that is not something you fix overnight
now there's no question most are
sticking with trump
more entrenched in his camp than ever
but there are those put off by it all
one lancaster republican who left the
party over the riot posted this tweet
with a photo of the local republican
office this week
it's trump sign still on the building he
says in the past when an election was
over the signs would come down and
people would start thinking about
governing
the fact it's still up two months later
he says shows
it's the party of trump mike armstrong
global news
lancaster pennsylvania later on tonight
i'm hosting an hour-long special about
stories that continue to dominate 2021
american politics
and the pandemic you can watch 2021 what
lies ahead later tonight on global
that is global national for this friday
i'm donna friesen
tonight here at canada is this beautiful
shot of the fraser river
in chilliwack bc a little bit of calm
for your day
please email your canada to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching i'll see you a little later for
our global news special for now take
care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
[Applause]
you